Welcome to "Ear Biscuits", the podcast.
Where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are listening to your voicemails
that you left at
♪ 1-888-EARPOD1 ♪
♪ One, one, one ♪
Answering the question, or
completing the sentence-
I said "one" three times,
which I guess was confusing.
But if you dial extra numbers-
Well yeah, then you just
get the extension 11,
which is us.
I could not have survived
my teenage years without,
fill in the blank.
Boop!
Boy. Boy, boy, boy, boy, boy, boy,
boy, boy, boy, boy.
Boy?
Is that all you gotta say?
You thought I was gonna start talking?
Boy.
Well, no, I was just thinking
about what I couldn't have
survived. My...
And actually, you know what?
We got a lot of answers that were in the,
when I think about my teenage
years and what I couldn't have
survived without,
I think about, uh, whacking off.
Okay, right.
And I'm just saying
that apparently many of
you also agree with that
because I would say that
more than 50% of the answers
were people talking about masturbation.
No. They're, no, they weren't.
Yeah, they were.
Oh really?
Yeah.
No, they weren't.
Am I right?
They were.
Yes.
Oh, they were?
Yeah. I'm not,
this is not a joke.
Oh.
This is based on knowledge
that I have about all the calls
that were made.
Over half?
Just about.
Which is a good amount.
I mean, I'm saying over 50% of you-
Well, you know what? Know thy self.
said that you could not have gotten
through your teenage years
without masturbating.
Do you think? Okay.
And you know what?
I'm right there with you.
So we're not gonna talk about that,
other than right now.
We're getting it out of our system.
That's it. That's all
the masturbation talk.
That's kind of what it is, isn't it?
Getting it outta your system?
Well, it's-
It doesn't really
work that way, though.
It seems to always
be ready to go again at some point.
Yeah. It's this is a.
I mean, there is a reset period, but-
It depends on how old you are.
Oh, really?
The older you get, the
longer the reset period gets.
I mean, I do recall
when I was,
when I was really,
making it into an art form that I-
Testing the limits?
I would, I challenged myself.
Mm hmm.
Just to see what would happen.
We didn't, we don't have
to talk about this now.
Oh, okay.
We don't have to.
You're the one who brought it up.
No, they brought it up.
And we didn't select any of those?
No.
We're not-
so we decided,
Yeah, we can talk
about it now.
We decided not
to talk about it.
Except now.
I didn't even know we
didn't even select those.
Yeah, I know.
I was trying to keep it from you.
You called them.
I didn't think your
ears were ready for it.
I know it makes you uncomfortable.
I mean, I think I could have survived
without it, but I mean-
Uh.
The thing that I, if I had
to do it multiple times,
just string 'em together,
that's what I couldn't have survived.
Cause that's, that's a lot of work.
That takes a lot.
I don't understand. I
lost, I lost the plot.
Don't make me say it.
If you, if you wanna string them together,
like rapid succession,
when I was testing the limits of-
Mm hmm.
It's just,
that's a lot of work.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're still lost?
It gets where it's almost not enjoyable.
Oh, okay.
It's almost like a duty.
Right.
Mm hmm. It's like, you're just a donor.
Right, yeah.
I gotta get paid.
.
Oh man. If we keep this up,
this would be like me
and my Dad's podcast.
Yeah. I heard it's really dirty.
He's a dirty boy.
I egg him on, you know, it's fun.
We're having a good time over there.
Speaking of having a good time,
I am excited about listening
to these voicemails
and I just like it.
I'm also, I like have a good time.
Mm hmm.
I like have a good time.
Is that what I said?
And the best time that I've
ever had on the internet
was Good Mythical Evening.
Well, that was really,
that was why I was talking about,
I went ahead and just broke the seal
and started talking about masturbation.
It had nothing to do with
Good Mythical Evening.
Well, but it's the kind of
thing we would talk about
out there.
It's an adult thing.
We'd talk about it there
and we would probably, we would use-
No.
more explicit language.
Okay. Sure.
Yeah, we would.
Because it's an R-rated version
of Good Mythical Morning, I gotta say.
If you were there for it.
It made waves last year.
Then you know you wanna
be there for it again,
'cause we're doing it
Thursday, September 1st.
All right? We're doing it that evening.
For one night only, ticketed event,
exclusively on Moment House.
That's the provider.
Don't get too worked up.
Yeah, yeah.
Grab your tickets at
goodmythicalevening.com, Friday.
Or if you're a Mythical Society member,
you can get it Wednesday.
Yeah, those society members, they're
always getting things early.
They're early.
But yeah. Good Mythical Evening.
I'm, it's September 1st, like I said,
so I'm already gearing up for it.
Yeah. You gotta make plans for it.
Yeah.
You gotta save up.
I'm gonna challenge myself this year.
In what way?
See how many I can string together.
How many Good Mythical Evenings.
Oh, okay. Okay, I understand.
I only did one evening, last time.
I'm gonna cram two evenings
into one this year.
Ay, ay, ay. I'm, I don't know
if I'm prepared for that.
Yeah, if you, if you don't
know, last year Link-
Had fun.
he got a little carried away.
We knew that we were going
to be taking some shots
to get ready,
but we underestimated
how much of a lightweight he is.
And as soon as he started talking,
I was like, "Whoa, okay."
I thought this was gonna be
like a progressive evolution
over the course of the night.
But it was just like, "No, no, no."
Bam! Out of the can.
Yeah, yeah. We are starting full on.
So I just basically have
made a commitment that I'm,
that I'm gonna be right there with you,
this time.
Boom.
So now that I know what to expect-
Stevie's not listening to this, so.
poor, poor Stevie. Poor Stevie.
She's gonna be the one to
have to keep us on track.
She was petrified. She
was petrified last year.
A lot of people watching were petrified.
Yeah.
It was fun.
And it's more fun if you're there.
Let's-
Go to mythicalevening.com.
Mm hmm. Let's listen to a response.
Am I playing these?
Well, you've got the computer.
Okay.
Hi Rhett and Link. My name is Kat.
I could not have survived my teenage years
without the lunches that
my Mom packed for me.
Specifically, I had braces
for a very long time.
Okay.
So my teeth were always sore
and she would always make
me ramen in a thermos
and the noodles would
soak up all the liquid.
Oh yes.
And every time I opened the thermos
it looked like a brain, so-
Ew.
I guess I couldn't have
survived my teenage years
without ramen that looked like a brain.
Thank you.
You're welcome, Kat.
What a pleasant voice that Kat's got.
She could be in radio.
Could be in radio? Could
be in podcasting, right?
Welcome to the future.
No, no, no, no.
The radio standard is a little
bit about above podcasting.
Did your Mom ever pack
you ramen in a thermos?
I like to go into a bit of a radio voice,
from time to time,
but I gotta tell you,
that I do think that a podcast voice
is a little bit more suited
to what we're doing right now,
but I am full ron ready.
To go radio?
To go radio if I
have to.
Don't do it.
I'll do it in a heartbeat.
I would love to have a late-night show
where I was talking to people about aliens
and weird and stuff like that.
Like Coast to Coast.
Coast to Coast, too.
I might do that in my old,
in my old days, in my elder times,
where you just sit there
and you listen to people
and you give them the
benefit of the doubt.
You don't question them.
You never question where
they're talking about,
you just egg them on.
Right.
And you just have a
crazy old conversation.
I love that idea.
I love it too. You're invited.
Oh, okay.
I'm working on it.
You're working on it?
I'll work on it.
Huh.
Who's doing Coast to Coast now?
It's still happening.
And in fact I was listening,
first of all, just so you know,
we're gonna have to do a podcast
about aliens before long, because-
Well, they're gonna arrive.
we just keep talking about it so much.
And we haven't even
let the Mythical beasts
in on the fact that,
there's lots of alien talk
that's been happening around here
in between us and amongst friends.
Mm hmm.
And you know,
my days of extreme skepticism about that,
well, I'm still a skeptic,
but you know, I don't know,
maybe LA's finally getting to me,
but we gotta talk about
it before long man.
And anyway,
I was listening to a podcast,
where they were talking about aliens,
which there's a few of them.
Mm.
We won't be breaking
any new ground.
Nope.
And the guy was talking
about Coast to Coast
and he was talking and
he was saying that like,
"Yeah, you were on Coast to Coast."
And he was like, "Yeah.
With, with the, with the, with the,
with the, with the,
you know, the old boy-"
What's his name?
whatever his name is.
Coast to Coast host.
He's still doing,
you said "hosta".
"Coast to Coast hosta".
So you just...
Uh, Jim?
George Noory. Yeah, George Noory, yeah.
He's still doing it.
From 1988 until now.
He's still doing it. George Noory.
George Noory, I can't really,
I don't, I can't do an impersonation,
but he does take everyone very seriously.
That's his schtick, I love it.
Look at what Kat got you on.
She got you on aliens.
She was just talking about,
her Mom made her ramen in a thermos, dude.
My Mom would make me a
thermos full of stuff
and I would love it.
She didn't make you a thermos.
She would-
She took out some soup,
warmed it up and put it
in a thermos.
Have you ever heard
about make a pot of soup?
Yeah. You're not making the pot.
Make a thermos of soup.
She didn't make, she got it,
used canned, man.
Stay out of this.
Your Mom was-
This is between me
and my mom.
Your Mom was putting canned
soup into your thermos.
You know what else she
was putting in there?
That's more than you were doing.
She was also putting
Hamburger Helper in there.
That was my jam.
Hold on, hold on.
Cheeseburger, Hamburger
Helper in a thermos?
That was my favorite.
It was better as a leftover,
like I loved it so.
How did you eat it out of there?
Did you pour it out and
eat it with a spoon?
I just dipped it out with
a spoon. You were there.
I don't watch that kind of
thing when it's happening.
Somebody eating Hamburger
Helper out of a thermos?
I blocked it out.
Because it kept it hot.
Well, I understand that.
But then when eating it,
you're sticking a spoon all the way down
in the bottom of a thermos?
What kind of spoon did you have?
How? Your thermos is that big.
You got an extra long spoon?
I don't remember that part.
Gee, maybe it's all a lie.
I'm disturbed thinking about it.
So I really relate to this ramen.
I never had braces.
I wish I did, but that ship has sailed.
Well, here's the thing.
I had 'em and then I was given that,
you know, I was given that
permanent bottom retainer.
'Cause something about the human mouth,
the bottom teeth are the ones
that like to venture back.
Keep, keep moving?
And then, you know,
just, not too long ago,
10 years ago, the dentist is like,
"If that thing's bothering
you, we can take it off."
He took it off and gave me a
retainer, that I had to put in,
at which point the reality
intersected with me,
which means I don't do things,
like continue to wear retainers,
because that requires a certain level
of focus and discipline that I don't have.
And so-
Well then, why did you say?
Oh you.
And so my bottom you've got crooked.
Actually, I can't.
Lift your chin up, dude. Or
where your chin would be.
Tilt your head up.
I'm showing you the outline right there.
Oh my God.
It's very clear. Doing that's
not gonna show you anything.
Oh yeah. Yeah, I gotcha.
It's not as bad as mine though.
Mine are janked.
Definitely not as bad as yours,
but-
Well not janked, but.
I will say that most people.
Why did you tell 'em
to remove the retainer?
It's not, it wasn't bothering you.
You, it had been in there for 30 years.
No. Every single time
I went to the dentist,
they would be like,
"Oh, you got a lot of
build up on this retainer."
Oh. Okay, whatever.
So, I mean-
Well hold on, but I'm, but what I'm saying
is you shouldn't feel bad
about your bottom teeth.
I don't know what it is,
but bottom teeth being crooked,
not really seen as a problem.
Just watch,
start looking at the bottom
teeth of actors on television.
American actors, I mean.
I'm not talking Brits.
They got, their teeth are
all over the place.
Yeah, totally.
I'm talking...
Oh yeah.
Okay. I love you, I love you.
I love you England.
I'm just, you know, it's a stereotype.
If anyone can take a joke it's them.
Yeah. You guys have taken over the world,
imperialism, all that.
We can make some jokes about you.
The bottom teeth of American
actors are regularly janked.
It doesn't matter.
And, uh.
Yeah. Look.
I mean, look at me, I'm successful.
Right. But if the top teeth
start getting outta whack-
And a lot of that success is from,
emanates from my face.
If the top teeth start
getting outta whack,
we have to start thinking
about casting decisions.
Okay? Does this,
does this cop seem like they
would have crooked top teeth?
Yeah.
Cause it's a different
thing, it's just a different thing.
Yeah, you're right.
Nothing against people
with crooked top teeth.
It's just a different thing,
it's a different casting.
You don't have anything
to say about school lunch?
My Mom stopped packing lunch
for me before high school.
So I didn't take lunch,
during high school.
Oh yeah. That's, that's true.
I didn't. I took my cut lunch-
I actually did a whole episode of this,
of talking about school lunch,
on Stevie's podcast,
"Best Friend's Back, Alright!".
All right.
You wanna check that out.
All right, let's play another one then.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
Yo.
My name is Keoni
and I could not have
survived my teenage years
without video games.
Let me tell you.
That stuff?
Stress reliever, okay?
Y'all are kind of old,
so like, you might not get it,
but that's alright.
Okay. Love you, bye.
You love us?
Kinda, kinda old.
You love us old guys?
They had video games when
we were coming up, man.
Yeah.
They just weren't good.
They weren't good.
They weren't as addictive.
They were not as immersive.
No.
I mean you can only-
They were definitely,
not as connecting.
Well, think about it.
You're watching Mario run sideways.
You feel, like, you are not Mario.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's not immersive.
I never once thought I was Mario.
You're not seeing Mario,
you're controlling someone else,
that you're watching.
Never once thought
I was "loo-ghee".
But once you move
into this first person perspective-
You think that's it?
now you got something that's
addictive in a different way.
I'm just kind of making this up as I go,
which is most of the time what I'm doing,
but I'm just saying, POV-
POV.
you know,
the amount of first person perspective
in your gaming experience,
that's how you relate
the level of addiction.
It's such a huge part of, I mean,
Lincoln's 17 now,
for the past, you know,
four years, five years,
it's a huge part of his
social life, you know?
Yeah.
He connects with his friends
playing video games.
I, you know, I understand
and respect that,
but at a certain point we're like,
"Let's do the real world thing."
Especially post pandemic.
We had to like shake him out
of those habits, a little bit.
Is he connecting with any NPCs?
Cause that's what you gotta
really work, watch out for.
What is that?
Oh, you haven't been
paying attention. Hmm.
Is that, that's a...
C'mon Dad,
get with the program.
What is that? A...
Non-Player Character.
It's just, you know,
an AI generated character
in a game that isn't,
it's just a, you know, it's an NPC.
Pertinent to the story?
Yeah, it might be pertinent to the story,
but it's-
Like an actor?
not controlled by a person.
Oh yeah.
It's not an avatar.
Okay. Yeah.
No, he's not.
You don't wanna make
too big of a connection
with an NPC 'cause then you're socially-
No, Rhett, these are
his real-life friends.
You're, but, I don't know,
because a lot of people
have a lot of connections
to NPCs and that can, again,
that can lead to, if you are-
I'll have to ask him.
If you, if your POV is
connecting with NPCs,
then you're SOL.
Then your SOL.
Exactly.
I knew where you were going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But Lily was never, Lily,
she never connected with friends,
playing video games with them,
even though she would play,
she'd play Overwatch a little bit,
back when that was the thing.
She didn't go to Fortnight-
Yeah, Shepherd she's
our video-
back when that was.
Shepherd's our gamer in the family.
He's the one that has his, like,
buddies that they regularly get on there
and play together.
Locke played like,
NBA 2K, for a while.
And then high school rolled around,
he completely stopped playing video games.
He just didn't.
Dunno, he just made decision not to.
And did other things.
Yeah, he was just, he was
just into different things.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah, for us,
it was never, you know,
I got Nintendo Power just so I could,
I got the subscription
just so I could talk,
talk the lingo,
but I just did not,
I just did not have the
commitment to beat any game ever.
Like it just did not
interest me that much.
And it never has since then.
Like I'm not, I know
there are certain points
when you're currently tempted.
You told me two days ago.
I'm thinking about it.
That you wanted to go away for a week.
Uh-huh.
And do nothing,
but play a video game,
like, 24 hours a day.
I didn't say 24.
When you weren't sleeping.
12 to 16.
You wanted to like, literally
like, become a gamer.
Well, okay, I'm glad you brought this up.
' Cause I have been thinking about it
and I just mentioned
it to you two days ago.
But-
I said that.
Yeah, I'm just saying it was,
it was that, I've been
thinking about it for a while.
It's only that you know
about it since then.
So, yes.
I do have a personality that if you put me
in like a challenging environment,
which is a video game,
in a lot of ways,
and there's a goal, and so
I can get fixated on that.
And I actually don't let
myself play video games
or even games on my phone really,
because I just don't,
I don't have time right now, right?
Were you done with Wordle?
Gave it up?
Uh, Wordle?
Wordle is not every single day anymore.
Wordle is like, a few times a week.
It's not the first thing in the morning.
So, but Wordle's not a game.
It is it's game, but yeah.
I understand.
So, but what I have,
I've had this idea, that
maybe in my older age,
when I don't have as
many responsibilities,
that I'll be like,
it would be cool to just say like,
I'm setting aside a certain amount of time
and I'm going to completely immerse myself
in one of these incredible games.
Having gone away from games
after the first Nintendo, pretty much.
You had a Genesis.
Yeah. That was same time,
same era.
You didn't care.
But I didn't even have a Super Nintendo.
I didn't even get on that train.
So, to come back to the system now
that is just so advanced,
and then be like,
I'm gonna get lost in
this immersive world,
and I'm just gonna see what it's like,
to just like, eat Cheetos,
drink Mountain Dew,
have a sleeping bag-
That's a stereotype.
next to a gaming chair.
I won't perpetuate.
I'll have a gaming chair
with like a sleeping bag next to it,
in like a cabin with a good WiFi.
And I'm gonna just
immerse myself.
Why does it have
to a cabin? That has
nothing to do with it?
'Cause I don't want anyone to see this.
It could be a closet.
Yeah, but I don't want
anyone to be close to me.
Well.
I mean smelling
like Cheetos and Mountain Dew.
Yeah, you'll be in a closet.
But I have to come out at some point,
and crap.
You wanna do this
for a week?
But I think,
but so then I started thinking,
"Why wait until I get old and do it,
and why not make it into
content while I'm still young
and people care about the content?"
Foray into the gaming.
So, Rhett takes a week,
goes deep into a game,
like what's the elder?
What's the one that everybody?
Elder Ring.
Elder?
Elden Ring.
Elden Ring? What's about,
what are the scrolls?
That's different?
Elders.
God, we don't know, man.
You got, hold on. There's
those old scrolls.
And then there's old rings
and which one's better?
I believe that the Elden Rings-
Elden Ring is a video game,
I just couldn't-
is it, is it one ring?
Or is it many rings?
Anyway, the thing I'm worried about,
is that I'll suck so bad
at the mechanics of it
because of all the buttons.
That's why VR is gonna leap frog,
bring me back into this.
Oh man, I gotta. I got a
VR headset and so do you.
Yeah.
Yeah it hurts.
Hurts my face.
You know, just wait for it.
Just wait for it, to be-
When is it gonna stop
hurting my face, man?
a new plan.
I wanted to be like "Ready Player One".
But you know what?
I get it, caller.
I couldn't quite understand your name.
It was quiet.
Well it, yeah, sort of
dropped out at that point.
I get it. I get it though.
Hey guys,
I could not have survived my
teenage years without my Crocs.
Now I know what you're thinking, "Shoes?"
Not only are they simulating,
what I imagine walking on clouds is like,
they're also reliable and sturdy.
Being a three-sport athlete,
the Croc is the most practical
shoe after your sport is over
and you wanna take off
your sweaty footwear.
I actually survived a hairy
moment in my Crocs too.
My mother wasn't paying attention one day
when she picked me up from school
and thought I was already in the car.
I wasn't.
She started driving off with
my foot underneath the tire.
My foot, the Crocs, unbroken.
That Croc saved my foot.
And let's not forget to
mention that a Croc can go
from cruise-control to
sport mode real quick.
Yep.
With a simple straps maneuver.
Anyways, thanks for listening.
Have a splendid week. Thanks guys.
Wow. Elise Myers.
Thanks for calling us.
Didn't she sound like Elise?
Yeah, a little bit.
A little bit.
Well also, I really
appreciate the fact that
you scripted that before you called in.
Don't, don't expose her.
No, I'm just saying that I,
no, I'm not making fun, I'm saying that-
I mean you don't, don't
crawl attention to it.
No, I liked it too, but.
I, no I'm saying I-
I don't want people to think-
You're the one making it
seem like it's a problem.
No, I'm not making it-
If you don't know what you're gonna say,
you can script it out and call in,
just like this person did.
But don't acknowledge it.
Make it seem like, "You know what?
That was a well put together call."
Can I just say it was a well-written call?
No! That's what I'm saying.
Because I have to believe that it was.
Cause now people are,
you're making people not wanna do that,
because they're gonna think
that you're gonna say-
I'm never say I'm gonna say it again.
I'm never gonna point it out.
This is a first caller who
read, who read their response.
If we think you reading your response,
we are not gonna say that.
And I'll never
acknowledge it.
I will never acknowledge it again.
Okay? Now let's talk about the content.
Right.
Okay?
We don't have to have a
meta-conversation about every call.
I mean-
Crocs.
I was hating on Crocs from a distance.
I gotta say, I mean
we're well into summer,
I haven't seen you,
I haven't seen you in a public
place with those Crocs yet.
You wore 'em one time to my house.
And I was wearing socks.
Yeah.
I put 'em on this morning
because I couldn't find my flip-flops.
But you didn't-
Without socks,
to take the dogs out.
Oh, well that doesn't.
And my feet
immediately feel sweaty.
Yeah.
Even, even before they are.
That's the problem.
And then they get sweaty in the Crocs.
Like I can't. I have to wear flip-flops.
And I'm not even a particularly
sweaty-foot person.
I bought some foot-sweat deterrent.
Why don't...
I like the Crocs with the socks.
I get it. I understand.
It's like they're in and out.
And then I like the sport mode, yeah.
If you need it, if you're gonna,
I didn't know that if
your foot got run over
while wearing them-
I think that was just luck.
I think that was luck.
I don't think Croc did anything,
but I did get some, you know, I...
When coming up I had my,
'cause I had very sweaty
hands and very sweaty feet.
As I've gotten older,
the problem has got much less pronounced.
Oh, but you couldn't have survived
your teenage years without?
Drysol.
How do you remember the name of that?
Because I don't know, man?
I, you know, I care about you.
I gotta be a repository
for the stuff that matters.
Well, there's a new
product that is better.
Didn't it work though? It was like a,
you would put a little drop on your hand-
It's the same thing, I think
and then a drop
on your other hand and
you rub 'em together
and then they wouldn't sweat?
Well, that was,
"wouldn't sweat" is debatable.
It wasn't like a miracle cure.
You know, you can get Botox in your palms,
if you've got really, like,
some kids, some teens will get Botox
in the...
Sure.
Does your glasses have a camera in them?
Because you just, like-
Sure, keep going.
I just, the way you grabbed.
Yeah.
You grabbed your glasses
in a way with two hands
that you never have, and it was like,
"Does he have those Facebook Raybans?"
Is he wearing those Facebook Raybans?
It's like, just keep doing
what you're doing? Yes.
First of all, have you seen ads for those?
The Facebook Raybans?
No. What do you mean Facebook Raybans?
What, you don't know about this?
No.
This is months old,
but I saw an ad recently and I was like,
"Oh, that's still that, they're
still trying to do that."
I don't give a about Facebook.
You don't have to give a about Facebook.
Do you care about Raybans?
Yeah. What are you talking about, dude?
Rayban and Facebook, or Meta,
are collaborating on a product,
that is a stylish pair of classic Raybans,
that have a camera in them,
to capture all and share all
the moments in your life.
You don't know about this, man?
You need to look at billboards more.
'Cause there's one on a billboard.
That's how I was reminded of it.
You know what? That's good advice.
But it was-
I'm gonna start looking
at billboards more.
But it was like in the
news in a pretty big way,
like last year.
I promise you Rhett from now on,
I'm gonna be looking at billboards more.
So, I thought that maybe you had those.
I don't, we don't have to
get into a conversation
about that, but I think-
You're really tangent-prone today.
Yeah.
Stay on target man.
Okay.
We're talking about Crocs.
No, we're talking about hand sweat.
So I had Drysol,
there's a new product-
No, we weren't.
called Carp?
Put in,
Google "hand, sweat", "hand,
sweat, stopper, carp."
Cause they got all, this is,
I think it was a Kickstarter.
They have all kinds of stuff.
Carp? Like the fish?
Yeah, there it is.
Carpe. Nope.
Carpe Max, like "carpe diem".
So they have 'em for
your feet, your hands.
It's probably all the same stuff,
maybe in different concentrations?
Treat palmar hyperhidrosis.
That's what you had.
Uh-huh, and it runs in the family,
'cause my kids have it too.
So I basically-
Hand lotion.
This is not a sponsor, of course.
So I started,
you've seen the little,
speaking of like Crocs,
you've seen those little
leather slipper things
that I've been wearing,
which are like, kind
of like leather Crocs.
Yeah.
And a couple of weeks ago,
when the weather hadn't
quite heated up yet,
I could wear those and be like-
Right.
"This is okay."
I tried wearing 'em yesterday.
Oo boy.
And, or is it today?
Did I come in here with 'em on?
Who cares?
Yeah, it was today.
We do too much in one day.
It becomes two days in my mind.
Wow.
This morning
I came in here with those things on.
What'd you do with them?
I took 'em off and put on,
I have some other shoes here
and I put on other
shoes 'cause I was like,
"My feet are sweating too much."
And I was like, "I gotta get this stuff."
I have it. I ordered it.
I just haven't put it on my feet yet.
You have to put on your
feet every night, though.
It's not sexy.
I think? I don't know.
I'm not gonna, I'm not,
it may become a sponsor.
So I'm gonna look into it more
before I start getting concerned
about if it's gonna
stop up your feet pores.
Carpe, call us.
Well it literally,
it literally, physically-
I don't wanna do that-
clogs, I'm just gonna say,
it literally clogs your pores with,
I think some sort of
compound, maybe aluminum?
But don't quote me on that.
That then your sweat just
finds another way out.
Do you like Crocs?
Not with socks.
So your feet don't sweat in Crocs?
I don't have any.
Well, yeah you do.
You were given the red
Crocs the same time I was.
And then I, I gave them to the-
Yeah you gave 'em away.
I donated them to the company.
Somebody here at Mythical has them.
Yeah.
Size 12.
We're great bosses.
I see people wearing my
clothes every occasionally.
Yeah, yeah. If we have
clothes that we don't like,
and we don't want anymore,
we give it to our employees.
I see my clothes all the time round here.
And we don't dock their pay.
No.
It's an honor system.
They dock their own pay.
Yeah. Right, right, right.
You decide what it's worth.
All right, let's take another. Oh.
Hey Rhett and Link.
This is Nico calling from Pittsburgh, PA-
What up?
and I definitely could not
have survived my teenage years
without Mountain Dew.
Easy way of summing it up,
as someone who now graduated high school
eight years ago now,
feeling old just saying that,
when you're a drummer
in a band growing up,
you learn that if you wanna melt faces,
you gotta "do the Dew",
you gotta have that energy
coming from somewhere,
especially when energy drinks
are not only dangerous,
but a little on the pricey side.
At least, it's how it was back then,
and I know it's pretty much how it is now.
But definitely could not have survived it
without good old Mountain Dew
and that's any variety too.
Okay. All right. Nico.
Except for Baja Blast, there.
Thanks guys.
Thanks for calling.
I think Nico might be a toll-booth worker.
Yeah. Well it's funny.
I mean-
Just based on the sounds.
I'm just trying to piece
together the setting.
If you're gonna talk about Mountain Dew-
You might as well be...
its appropriate
that there's like engines
revving in the back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People are "doing the Dew"
behind him or all around him.
Yeah. He could be at one of those.
Sometimes people will
gather in parking lots
and play around with remote-control.
Have you seen how crazy
the remote-control stuff
can get these days?
Have you, have you, have you a been-
We're talking about "the Dew", man.
I'm just following the,
I'm just following my instincts today.
It's like you're, man, your...
You're speaking of Mountain Dew.
I'm just saying-
No. What? No.
Have you just been out
and about in this town
and then all of a sudden
it's just like outta nowhere-
I've seen remote-control planes.
No, no. I'm talking like-
Drones?
I'm talking to like a real,
a badass-
Car?
car just comes outta nowhere.
And then you're like,
"Where's the Dad and the son?
Where are they?"
Right.
And then you see them.
Well, whoa,
you're walking where? In like a-
I've this, I've been, I have been-
parking lot to a Gelson's?
I've been cornered by
remote-control vehicles,
seven times in my time in LA.
Sometimes I've been on a trail.
Sometimes I've been in a parking lot.
Sometimes I've been on the sidewalk.
Sometimes I've been
walking down the street
in my neighborhood.
Bam! There it is.
I prefer to be in the thing that's moving.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah. I'm not saying I'm an advocate.
I'm just saying I'm just-
You sound like an advocate.
I'm just saying I'm just,
this is an awareness play.
We can relate to this Nico though,
because we couldn't have gotten through
without Mello Yello.
Oh God. What?
I mean,
how much Mello Yello did we drink?
I mean, we just, we
couldn't drink enough of it.
Like I, we felt like it was like,
it was like we had an
exclusive deal with it.
I guarantee you didn't
drink as many as me.
Of course not.
'Cause I would get home.
I know.
I would get home and we did
not keep them in the fridge
because they moved too fast.
My Mom kept her diet Coke
and caffeine-free diet Coke,
depending on the time of day,
in the refrigerator.
The Mello Yello was kept,
you know where it was.
On the floor.
On the floor next to the
onion and potatoes box.
Everybody had that.
Yeah.
And then I would get
home from a hot, hot day.
I would reach down, I'd
pop that thing open.
I'd grab a Mello Yello.
I'd, I'd swig-
Pound it.
I'd pound the first one.
Then I'd get a second one
and go sit down with it.
Both hot.
Both hot and both full,
carbonated, sugary,
caffeinated drinks.
Oh gosh.
The first, I didn't understand
what was happening.
Yeah.
We didn't-
We didn't have
the education.
No one told us
about caffeine.
Like I would go home and
pound five cigarettes.
It just-
This is not the fifties.
No.
This is the eighties.
I mean, but it kind of feels
like cigarettes, you know?
Well, we didn't know.
We didn't know about sugar.
In the same way
that like we weren't educated on,
you just can't pound a bunch
of Mello Yello's like that.
It didn't have an impact on us.
But do you ever remember
making the connection
between caffeine-
And being wired?
and like being, "I can't sleep tonight.
Must have been those seven
Mello Yello's I had at dinner."
Never.
How come? The internet makes
people so much smarter.
You know, it makes 'em dumber too,
but just think about
how dumb we were, man.
We didn't know anything.
Were there kids in the eighties
who knew about this stuff?
I had, when's the last
time you had a Mello Yello?
I wanna go get one right now.
Every time we talk about this,
this is how this part
of the conversation is.
Do you think we could find one right now?
They have em' at a gas station?
If you go to one of those,
like 100 soft drink,
fountain drink machines.
The Coke?
Coke machine? Like Five Guys have one.
Coke remix? What is it called?
Coke?
Yeah.
Oh man. They got 'em in the theaters,
at the AMC theaters, I think.
Yeah.
Five Guys has one and you
can get a Mello Yello Zero.
Yeah, yeah. I've had it.
And you know what?
I'm tempted to just start
ordering those off the internet,
but I don't want to-
No, no, no.
I don't wanna be drinking
a bunch of those.
Look, I'm not a doctor.
I like it being a treat.
I don't think you should make diet soda
or definitely not soda,
but I don't think you
should make diet soda
a part of your daily routine.
Because that diet soda
does some stuff to your,
to your biome, like your gut biome.
And I just don't think
you need it in there.
Those artificial sweeteners, man,
we don't know what they're doing.
It might be worse than
sugar. Probably not.
But like I just have it
as an occasional treat
while I'm here at the office.
Don't get started on 'em.
That's what I think too.
But I happen to be looking
at a Reddit thread.
This guy, he might have been on Twitter?
He wasn't a billboard, though?
He quit, wasn't a billboard.
He said, "I quit diet Coke.
I've been drinking it my whole life.
Oh I saw this.
I quit for a whole month.
I'm here to report-"
I'm here to report.
"My life has not changed for the better.
I haven't, I haven't
gotten in better shape.
I haven't lost weight-"
Well, he went on to say that,
"I'm not happy anymore."
"I don't feel any different.
I'm not happy-"
It wasn't-
I'm just not happy anymore."
Yeah.
He was like, yeah.
And then all these
people were talking about, "Hey man,"
people were like, coming
into the thread and saying,
"Well you know, I tried all these things
to make my body better.
And then I got cancer. So drink
your, drink your diet Coke."
And I was like, "Gosh."
This is like a, what's the word?
Like, a jaded group of
society where they're like,
kind of snarky and jaded?
Can't think of the word.
Snarky and jaded people.
You're thinking about-
Nihilists?
No, just a little bitter.
Is it the nihilists?
A little bitter.
You know, it does suck, this like,
if you try to do everything right,
and you try to be healthy,
you gotta choose your,
you gotta choose your moments, at least.
Your like, your happy little indulgences.
I'm not gonna judge anyone for doing it.
I'm just-
For drinking your,
but people were like
coming out of the woodwork
to tell this guy,
"Go back to drinking your diet Coke."
Yeah. But here's the thing.
The thing-
If you're not happy.
the thing you were
probably really enjoying
in the diet Coke is the caffeine.
There are other vehicles for caffeine.
Here's one of 'em right here.
Not a sponsor, but we drink
the hell outta this stuff,
this Yerba Mate.
That's better for you than diet Coke.
And coffee. They're finding-
Yeah, right.
Here it is right here.
Coffee.
They're finding it now
that people who drink coffee specifically,
there was a study that said that people
who drink coffee sweetened...
So people who drink coffee
are less likely to get,
I think it was cancer?
But people who drink sweetened coffee-
He thinks it was cancer.
for some reason are more unlikely to,
like 30% less likely,
now that's just one study,
but there's other sources of caffeine.
But while we're talking about that
and I said the thing about gut biome,
I have to also talk about,
I've told you about the
Kefir kick I'm on right now.
And I have to, and I have to tell you.
I love Kefir but I can't get it
in a big enough container.
Well, you get multiple of small ones.
I don't like that.
But let me tell you.
There's only like two
and a half servings in a,
in the thing of Kefir.
I, listen,
I know you think-
Yeah tell 'em.
you might just think, we just went all LA.
We did. We did.
I love Kefir, it's tangy.
I love yogurt.
It's milky.
But the,
and I am not one of these people that-
Mm, my mouth is watering right now.
like talking about like probiotics
and like, I, you know,
a lot of probiotics
just like, is kind of BS
and doesn't really get through
your system or whatever.
But let me tell you right now.
So, I just had this idea
that I was gonna get back
into Kefir because I liked it.
But I was like,
what I usually do is I get
one and I go through it
and then it takes weeks
to get the second one.
Right.
It doesn't become a part
of my routine.
Yeah, and you
go through it quick, right?
And so I just told Jessie, I was like,
"I would like you to have three things.
Kefir,
kimchi-
Okay.
and kombucha.
Oh, the.
And it's unfortunate,
those are three K's.
Three K's. Yeah.
There's gotta be a better
way to refer to them.
Yeah.
So I'm working on that.
I'm workshopping the way I refer to those,
'cause it cannot be the "KKK" diet.
Cause that's not, it's not gonna be that,
okay?
No you can't, you can't.
But-
You know what?
It already exists, probably.
It's a sad,
this is a sad reality.
So those three K's obviously
are all very probiotic.
Lots of people just consider these things
to be like "life tonics", right?
And so I was like,
"I like all three of these
things. I feel good."
But the one that I have
not wavered from at all,
for about three months is Kefir.
Either, if I don't have it in the morning,
I have it at night and
I get at least a cup.
Mm hmm.
Throw some granola
in there, throw some berries in there.
Oh, you eat it as a meal.
You eat it as a snack, meal, drink.
This is the ticket.
For breakfast lately,
I've been doing cereal,
but instead of milk it's Kefir.
Oh listen, don't write that down,
'cause I'm gonna put it in my recipe book.
But-
I, I don't like this idea,
but go ahead.
Okay. But the,
really the thing I'm
trying to communicate here
is that give Kefir a chance.
This is what happened.
What happened?
I started, I was gonna
say I started taking it,
I started eating it.
And I didn't have anything
in mind other than-
Can you make it like Mountain Dew,
you started "doing" it.
I started doing Kefir.
Doing the Kefir.
And I was, and I forgot-
Brilliant marketing,
by the way, Mountain Dew has like,
has subconsciously said they're a drug.
Okay, let me,
I gotta get this out.
Get it out!
You keep interrupting me. Okay, so.
I start drinking Kefir.
And then I just kind of
forgot that I was doing it,
but it had become a daily thing.
I'm having a conversation
with my therapist
and I told him, I'm like,
"You know, I'm a generally happy person."
Right? I am, I'm a pretty happy person.
You know, I haven't,
I have never been like
diagnosed with depression
or anything like that.
I go through, like anybody,
I go through like depressive
states or sad states
or whatever, but I'm pretty happy.
But I kept finding myself,
over the course of a couple of weeks,
with no external thing to explain it,
being like, I keep
realizing that I'm happy.
Okay? It was just weird.
'Cause it hadn't happened before.
I'm not the kind of person who
realizes that they're happy
and like stops and thinks, "I'm happy."
That's, that's strange. Noted.
Yeah.
Started talking
to my therapist about it.
And then I was like,
didn't pick up on it in the first session.
But then like a couple of
sessions, a couple of weeks later,
I was like, "The only thing
that is different, is Kefir."
You think Keffir's
made you happy?
Okay. So, so.
Okay, you think I'm crazy,
and I probably am.
But I go on Reddit, your favorite website,
and
I search in Kefir
and then all these people
are saying the same thing.
That it has, the other
thing I noticed is that,
how do I put this mildly?
My dooky was good.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Like to put it bluntly.
Like that I was regulated.
In a way that I've only been regulated
if I started taking supplemental fiber,
which I just don't like doing,
'cause it's hard to keep
up with and it sucks.
Yeah.
But Kefir had the same impact
on my gastrointestinal system
that supplemental fiber did.
But also my mood was elevated.
And of course I haven't read,
I'm sure you're all like,
"Oh there's all these..."
I know there's all these
books about your gut biome
and the neurons in your stomach.
And there's all this science behind it
that I'm not familiar with.
But I'm just saying anecdotally,
as just a dude who's been
eating a lot of Kefir,
I'm telling you right now.
You scraped out the sad-causing bacteria,
and replaced it with happy bacteria.
I don't know, but then,
literally, I'm not kidding.
You forgot to take it.
I ran outta Kefir
like a month ago. Okay?
I went for 10 days without eating Kefir.
And I found myself, I woke up one day
and I'm like, "I'm sad. What's different?"
And I was like, "It's the damn Kefir."
Got to Kefir, told Jessie,
"We gotta have Kefir. We can't run out."
You got back to the Kefir?
Got back to the Kefir.
Are you?
I'm two weeks back
into Kefir, I'm happy.
I, it could, it's probably
totally psychosomatic.
I understand that.
But I'm saying, it could
be a placebo effect?
But you should try it.
I like it.
But here's the thing.
I like being happy.
Don't stop. Just keep it coming.
Keep it going.
Doesn't come in a big enough container.
Is there like a cheap version of it?
Get two.
I, you know, it's pricey.
You can afford it.
I need it in bulk, man.
You can afford Kefir.
It's a lot better than Mountain Dew, Nico.
That's ultimately what I was saying.
If we could just get
Kefir to be caffeinated,
we'd be, maybe that could be a product.
It's like, it's drinkable
yogurt that makes you happy.
Hey listen. I swear by it.
Pretty good.
Keffir's a keeper.
You know, I can come up with all kinds
of funny things to say
on how I survived my teenage years,
but in all due honesty,
I really could not have
survived my teenage years
without my, you know, my support group,
my friends, my family.
Because I was a way different person
as a teenager than I am now.
I hated who I was as a teenager,
but I've definitely grown more like,
especially since high school,
high school was bad for me,
But yeah, I literally
could not have survived
my teenage years without my friends,
because the way my personality was,
I probably would've just
spiraled into a deep depression-
Hmm.
and I'm glad
I'm in a way better place than I am now.
So thank you for
listening, Rhett and Link.
Love you guys.
I love this response.
Wow.
Isn't this great?
It might be better than Kefir.
I know this, that was like,
that was like Kefir in a voicemail.
Yeah. And he didn't give his names.
So I think, we could call him Kefir.
Kefir Sutherland just called
in to the, to the pod.
Thanks for sharing that.
You make an excellent point,
that when you're in your teenage years,
you are not in your final form.
Mm.
And it, you can,
you can change for the better.
And sometimes it's just
about weathering the storm
of being a teenager to get to
the next phase of your life,
where you can start to pull it
all back together, you know?
Or pull it together for the first time.
I tell my kids this all the time.
And I, you know, I was talking
to Locke the other day.
He's 18. He's going off
to college in the fall.
Mm hmm.
And I don't remember the
context of the conversation.
I just remember saying,
"You have no idea how
much you're gonna change
over the next four years.
Like you are going to change more-"
Oh yeah.
"statistically speaking,
over the next four years
than you will ever change
in any additional four years,
subsequent four years, for
the rest of your life."
And I was like, "That's, that's exciting."
Not that you need to
change, but you need to,
you need to understand just
how wet your concrete is.
Ha.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I like that.
And just revel in that wetness, man,
you know what I'm saying?
Because it gets harder
and harder and harder.
Well, I don't know.
You know, you say revel in it,
but it makes me think, okay,
you gotta be strategic about who,
you know, who you...
To Keffir's point.
Oh, you can screw it up for sure.
Who you, you know.
What you expose yourself
to when you're morphing,
you know?
You're morphing into who you're gonna be,
at a rate greater than any
other point in your life
when you're a teenager.
So it's like, you gotta, you
gotta be thinking about that.
And I mean, you're talking
about end of college years too,
which yeah, you know,
you're still in teen years.
But who you, who your people are,
it like makes a big difference.
Show me your friends and
I'll show you your future.
Yeah, man.
I mean, I'm so grateful for the friends
that we had in high school,
and we've talked about them.
The friends that we have
in college, like, you know,
we're going to Denver in
like, in a handful of weeks,
we're gonna have like a
college-friend getaway in Denver.
The fact that like,
we're still connected to these people,
who actually care about us.
It's like, it's an awesome
feeling to know that like,
Mm.
you can, somebody cares about you
and there's no strings attached, you know?
You got-
Yeah.
having a support structure is so important
and it's not something that you can just,
you know, you can't put a,
I guess you could put a
"want" ad in the paper
or whatever the app
version of that is now,
there's a digital way to do that.
Even if you look at Mythical Beasts,
I draw lots of comfort
and just inspiration,
knowing that there's
people who've connected
because of our content.
But then it's more about their
connections with each other
than it is with us now.
That's freaking awesome.
Mm.
You know, I mean,
whether it's because of
us or something else,
I mean, yeah, he makes
a great point that like,
that having a few key people in your life,
that love you and you know, you can trust,
makes all the difference in the world.
And so I think about the
people who don't have that
and it's like, but you can get it.
Like, that's the hope
in this is that like,
he said, "With my personality
and what I was prone to
at that phase of my life, like,
I don't think I would've made it.
I wouldn't make it to become the person
that I was destined to be, so to speak,
if it wasn't for people
there along the way."
To, I don't know, you know,
he didn't fill in the gaps,
but we all need to do that for ourselves.
Yeah. And I think that, you know-
To provide support
direction, fill in the blank.
They, inherent in that message is,
you don't have to be a teenager
for this to be applicable,
but,
regardless of how hopeless you feel
at this moment,
don't let this moment,
these circumstances, define.
Don't let the present define your future,
I guess, is a better way to say it, right?
It's so hard to do that.
It's very difficult to do that.
Yeah.
That's why people could
be helpful in that.
But sometimes you like,
because even when it comes
to the choices you're making,
that, I mean, the whole,
"Show me your friends and
I'll show you your future."
The reason that makes sense,
and to some degree,
it's not, you know,
it's not like, an airtight
always true thing, but.
The reason is that we, a lot of times
make decisions about who we're
gonna surround ourselves with
based on current needs.
Needs for acceptance, most often.
Need for belonging.
And those things are not
bad in and of themselves.
But if you're finding
acceptance and belonging
with people who don't have
your best interest in mind,
then your future self,
wishes they could come
back to your present self
and say, "Ah, don't make that decision."
So that's the thing,
try to anticipate, "What would
my future self want me to,
what kind of decisions would they want me
to make right now?"
It's very tough to do
that, but you have to try.
You have to try to.
Yeah.
Especially when it comes to
who you're choosing to associate with.
Yeah.
That phrase of like "Finding your people,"
is something that we
use in our home a lot.
For every stage of life, you know,
whether it's Lando assimilating
into elementary school
and now moving on to middle school
and then Lincoln moving
through middle school
and high school
and Lily finding her way
and her people in college,
like at every stage.
And then you think about us, like even,
you know, like post-college
and moving out here to California.
We had each other and we had our families,
but we had to find a few more friends.
We had to find some people.
Yeah.
That we could count on, you know?
And until we did, it felt tenuous,
you know, moving out here.
Oh, for sure.
Then you just have,
we had a couple of close friends
that we kind of jumped
into really quickly,
and those are very sound
decisions, you know?
Mm hmm.
Still close to them.
But you know, just adding
to that group and this,
it doesn't have to be big.
But you, it's important no matter what.
So this is not a teenage thing.
Mm hmm.
But yeah,
I'm so glad that you called in, Kefir.
Let's hear another one.
Hello, Rhett and Link.
My name is Savannah
and I could not have
survived my teenage years
without fan fiction.
What?
Yep.
And just so you know,
fan fiction doesn't have to
be super sexual and weird,
it can just be like a normal story
about your favorite characters,
just going on a silly little adventure.
And that's the kind of
thing that I like to read,
and write, eventually.
So I got into fan fiction
when I was around like 12
and I started writing at like 13.
And then throughout middle
school and high school,
I wrote a crap-ton of fan fiction,
'cause I was also homeschooled.
So I was very bored.
Oh.
So, I actually wrote over 250,000 words,
up until I started college
and got way too busy,
which is like, two-plus books I think?
Roughly, if you average 'em out
and that's not even a lot compared
to most fan fiction writers.
So yeah. I still love writing.
But fan fiction is like
my weird little hobby
that I don't tell anyone about
because people hear fan
fiction and think sex-kink.
So yep. That, that's it.
Thank you, Susanna. We don't think-
Savannah.
Savannah?
Savannah. Yep.
Savannah.
Savannah, if you wanna call back in
and talk about being a furry too,
you can debunk some of that stigma.
Oh, come on. You don't know that.
They're not always, this,
it's not a Venn-diagram-
I'm not saying.
is not a circle.
It's not. I'm just, that
was my way of saying,
"Thank you, Savannah, for
dismantling the stigma
of fan fiction for me."
Fan fiction is not fan friction.
It's a sub genre.
Yeah.
Well, and we don't know that,
I mean-
Well.
Our experience with fan fiction
is just being uncomfortable
reading stuff about ourselves,
for a gimmick-
Well.
on the show.
I do know someone.
Okay.
And you also know this person.
Because the people who,
especially in fandoms that
are fictional to begin with,
I mean, it's one thing for
there to be fan fiction
about two real dudes like us,
but I'm talking about like,
you've got a world that's
been built by an author
or a TV show or whatever.
Yeah, yeah.
And then, I mean that fan fiction,
which is basically people
just taking the world
that's already been built
and the characters that have existed
and telling new stories,
that kind of exist
within this world.
That was the world that
I didn't know about
until we met somebody who actually
has contributed significantly
to some of those things.
And it totally makes sense, first of all.
And one of the really exciting
things that's happening,
related to this, and again,
I'm not smart enough to
be able to explain it
or understand it,
but something with the blockchain.
With blockchain technology.
Oh are you talking
about collaborative storytelling?
Is making that, is easing
and encouraging that process
and inviting more people
and incentivizing more people
to be involved in that,
to actually be able to take
narratives and shape them,
which is pretty exciting stuff.
So actually I think,
I think that those who were the first
to begin writing fan fiction,
were actually just way ahead of the curve,
in terms of what we're all
going to be participating in,
when it comes to the way that
we relate to storytelling
in the future.
Because the more you can be involved,
to the point that you're actually
manipulating the outcome,
you know, influencing the outcome,
influencing the stories
or telling their own, your own stories,
like that's gonna be just
the way people interact
with stories a generation from now.
It's starting now.
Again, I'm not a really a student of it.
I just know smart people who
know more about it than I do,
who say things and I get 10% of it
and can then re-spit it out like this.
But I-
But it's exciting.
if you think about it in terms of, okay,
favorite book series, "Lord of the Rings",
it's, there's an incredible world,
that's been built and it's a playground.
I'm sure that there's
got to be fan fiction
all around the world of Tolkien, right?
So.
Of course.
I just found myself, well, I just don't,
I'm not a reader and
I'm not a writer, right?
So it's like, do I have to be?
What, you laughing at me?
No, I...
I mean, I can read.
Yeah.
And I can write.
Prove it.
But that is not,
you know, that's not
central to my identity,
it's not one of my major hobbies.
I, yeah.
You're making me defensive.
I, well.
I'm not a reader
and a writer.
I'm not-
You can snicker all you want.
What I'm saying is that the,
and also this is something that,
this is something that
Mike helped me understand
about Dungeons and Dragons,
which I didn't really understand,
the appeal of D&D-
Yeah, and... I-
but you're essentially-
It's making your own.
it's a collaborative storytelling process.
But my point, what I was getting at was,
I assume because I'm so
into the world of Tolkien,
that like, it just seems
like there's a barrier to,
okay, this is just a fan generated story,
it's not canon, so it's-
It's not Tolkien.
Yeah, so,
but like,
if you look at the Star Wars universe,
lots of fan fiction
there, absolutely as well.
Like every place you can
think of there's fan fiction,
but like with Star Wars,
it's not like everything's
George Lucas anymore.
It's like, you look at the
John Favreau stuff and-
Isn't the-
Yeah.
isn't the Mandalorian fan fiction?
Well, is it sophisticated?
Well-funded fan fiction,
but it's fan fiction.
Did George Lucas,
did the originator of the
story come up with it?
No, it was like-
Right.
"Oh, this is a story that we can tell."
That's what I'm getting at.
So what I'm saying is,
fan fiction is already here.
It's officially sanctioned.
It's just well-funded fan fiction
is on Disney+ or whatever, you know?
Yeah.
I'm just saying,
this is a revolution in storytelling.
But when it becomes canon,
like that stuff is, it's certified.
Yeah.
So then,
there's like buy-in.
Because when it builds a world
and especially with all
of the Star Wars stuff,
part of the fun for me is
like, fitting it all together.
But all you have to do-
You know?
cause I'm not gonna,
I'm not sitting around waiting
to write fan fiction.
So fan fiction,
there's a lot of fun that's,
when you don't care, beyond canon.
And that's the part that I don't,
I have never experienced it.
So I think that's my barrier to entry.
But you've experienced
the curated fan fiction,
as a person who likes to
watch television shows.
I know it could be entertaining
and there's really talented
people writing fan fiction,
I, in theory.
But I've not experienced it
and I'm just really curious how,
if I could get over that hurdle of like,
"I'm just reading this for the fun of it,"
but this didn't really
happen to this character.
But did the first thing
happen to the character?
No, because it's a fictional tale.
You think that Sam and Frodo
are actually best friends?
You know what?
One day you'll find out I'm
actually smarter than you.
You know. That's gonna blow your mind.
Oh, well, first of all,
why do you take anything
that I said as a critique
on your level of intelligence?
You laughed at me for not
being a reader or writer.
The only thing I laughed
at was when you said,
"Now I'm not a reader, or a writer."
It's like, that's just funny.
I thought it was a joke.
It's not a joke.
I thought you
were making a funny,
I thought it was pretty funny.
It was, I guess, unintentionally funny.
But what I'm saying is-
I'm just being me, man.
is that, I feel like my
eyes are being opened
to the possibilities.
Not in a way that I'm
directly contributing to,
or experiencing.
You're saying
the same thing I'm saying.
But I'm just saying that
I think it's pretty cool
what's happening.
And I think that it's
gonna be second nature
for our kids and our,
especially our kid's kids,
who are gonna grow up in
a world in which the lines
between the fan fiction that
Savannah's talking about
and the fan fiction that
everyone is experiencing,
which is just cool world-building
and stories that come from that world,
the lines are just gonna be blurred, man.
And then it's gonna be
like, is it good or not?
But what you're saying is that
somebody has to be in charge.
And I think this is where the cool,
and again, I don't understand it,
the cool sort of blockchain generated,
it's curated.
It's not completely just
like, "Oh, here's fan fiction
that would conflict with
this fan fiction over here."
But no, the collaborative
is creating fan fiction
that fits together and doesn't contradict.
Is consistent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right.
You're interested
in the consistency,
which I totally get that.
Right.
That matters to me.
And I think it matters
to most people, honestly.
But I'm just saying that
if you get that curated,
sort of semi-regulated fan fiction
and then regulated in terms of quality.
Like that's-
I'm open.
that's an exciting future.
And I'm also open to the kinky stuff.
So this is what I could not survive
my teenage years without,
I don't think it's that crazy,
but I'm 19 now and I still do this
and whenever I was really sad
or angry or just,
you know, really intense
feelings as a teenager,
I would crush bath bombs.
And my friends would
always gimme bath bombs,
'cause you know, I was taking baths.
But I would go in my bathroom like,
when, after my parents were asleep
and I would just like crush them,
like with my bare hands.
And it was actually really nice,
like it released a lot of stress.
You'd be surprised, but yeah.
Wow.
I like that.
Crushing bath bombs.
But not actually taking a bath with them.
Well, you could get a two-for-one.
Yeah.
Crush it
and let it crumble into the water.
Yeah.
And then you, I mean the
double stress relief.
What do you do when you're angry?
Physically.
When I'm angry?
I mean,
when I'm angry.
I mean, I have taken a walk.
Oh.
I've definitely inadvertently sent Christy
on a few walks.
Hmm?
That's,
Christy goes on walks when I perturb her.
You curse when you get upset.
I curse when I get upset.
I curse
when I get upset, yeah.
But when I was a kid,
my Mom told me to go punch a pillow,
which I actually did.
There's no satisfaction. This
is what I was getting at.
There's no satisfaction
in punching a pillow.
You remember in my room
when you walked into my room
and there was that hole in the wall.
Yeah.
And it was exactly the
diameter of my heel.
It was because I got mad
at my brother one time
and I kicked, like,
kicked the wall with my heel and you know,
goes, my heel, "Boom."
Got a high arch.
Yeah.
So it goes right through.
It was that way until-
So you, it was
like a donkey kick?
it was a side-
From the back.
no, it was sideways.
Oh, like a Bruce Lee?
It was a sidekick.
Oh.
And-
And you also
kicked the bleachers when
you were playing basketball
as a teen and broke your toe.
And I will say-
You're a kicker.
I'm well,
I'm also a puncher.
But not a closed-fist puncher
because I care about my hands.
I'm gonna be honest with you guys.
I'm gonna be vulnerable here.
Last week,
I was in my own bathroom
and I was going in and out of the closet.
Now I'm a tall man, and
I hit my head on door,
I would hit my head on more doorframes.
If they're not regulation, if
they're not six foot, eight,
I hit my head on 'em sometimes.
But I've actually gotten really good
at not hitting my head on things
because I subconsciously
lower my neck anytime,
lower my head,
anytime I go through a doorframe.
Hmm.
But sometimes with an
especially short door frame,
which for some reason,
the frame between my bathroom
and my bathroom closet
is pretty low.
And I normally don't think about this,
but I went into the closet,
went into the bathroom,
then forgot something
and did like a pivot,
where I took one step into the bathroom
and turned back around.
Bam! Hit my head.
Mm hmm.
The crown of my head.
Ooh!
On the doorframe.
The metal doorframe
where the thing slides.
Oh gosh.
And my immediate reaction
was to punch it!
It was just like-
Like palm-heel strike?
Palm-heel strike to the
wall next to the door.
I didn't hit the door because
the door is a big mirror.
I don't wanna break anything.
I don't wanna bleed it.
Josh will be proud with the-
Boom!
palm-heel strike.
And it was just like,
and Jessie was like, in the like,
Jessie was like 15 feet away.
And she was like, "Somebody's got issues."
Or something like, I
don't know what she said.
No, you just hit your head.
But no, but the reason I did it,
is because I was already
mad about something else.
And I don't even remember.
Mm hmm, mm hmm.
You never remember what
you were mad about.
That's right.
Comes out sideways.
What I'll say,
is that I've never hit a person in anger,
with the exception of John
Carson and John Enzor.
And one time that was in your defense.
You're welcome.
Okay.
But that was-
I never hit,
I've never hit a person.
And that was like,
almost 40 years ago.
But I've never hit a person in anger,
but I have hit a house, like a home.
If a wall is part of a home.
I'm not a striker.
I've hit a car.
I probably have hit a pole.
Okay.
They never seem to care.
Yeah. I mean,
I like crushing a bath bomb.
But this.
This is it.
The reason that-
Just keep,
just keep 'em stacked up.
The great thing about this.
Keep one in your pocket.
Punching or kicking SHEETROCK
and it giving a little bit,
gives you a sense of relief.
Pillows, they're not fighting back at all.
Bath bomb may be the
perfect thing, because-
It's like plaster.
it's like,
you're destroying it,
there's a sense of satisfaction,
but nobody's getting hurt.
Except the bath bombs.
Here's one.
Hailing Link.
Yo.
So my name's Danielle
and this is gonna be a very Gen-Z answer.
I could not have survived being a teenager
without the "block"
button on social media.
That thing was my best friend
throughout middle school
and high school.
And I wish there was an
in-person version of it.
Love you guys. Bye.
Ooh.
Oh yeah, Danielle.
The block button.
I mean, if I had to experience
social media as a teen,
man, I don't-
You wouldn't be here.
I don't know. I just don't know.
Would've done something
too stupid to recover from.
I mean.
Man, the block button.
Yeah. That, that.
Having a healthy relationship
with the block button
is probably a really good thing.
I've never blocked anybody.
Have you ever blocked anybody?
I've muted. I'm a muter not a blocker.
Okay. Like how much muting have you done?
Less than a dozen people in my life.
Okay.
So this is not a regular occurrence.
The reason, and again, Danielle,
if the block button got you through,
more power to you,
and I know that there's a difference
between the blocking and the muting.
Yeah.
When you, when you kick the,
the wall between you
and your brother's room
and he's in there,
then you have the added
benefit of him knowing
that you just put a hole in the wall.
But if he's not in there, you just,
you just got some anger out.
That's the difference
between a block and a mute.
Well, and also if you're
talking about Twitter,
I think I'm right about this,
if you block someone,
they cannot see your tweets
and they cannot include,
they can't tweet about you.
Like they can't like
put you in their tweets.
Oh, that's nice.
But I know that they can't
see your tweets anymore.
A mute just means that you can't
see anything that they say.
So there's a few, like the reason I,
again, this is a little
bit different probably,
for a public figure.
Yeah.
But,
blocking is
in one sense,
it can be,
because they know that it happened,
it can be seen-
It can be offensive.
as an act-
Like literally an act of
offense.
Yeah.
It is defensive,
but it's often interpreted
as an act of aggression,
even though it's not.
But because people,
it can be incendiary,
I guess it's what I'm saying.
And so if you want to just
ignore the fire, you mute.
If you want to,
you know.
The mute is more about
your experience only.
Yeah. Right.
And so that's the only reason I haven't
blocked anybody.
But then if you
don't want people,
I like what you, it is
a good point though.
If you don't want someone,
I guess, on Twitter,
dragging your name into a conversation,
then the block is effective with that.
For sure.
You know, in general,
I just wanna big up boundaries.
Mm.
Saying, oh,
that what, you know,
you're walking through your life.
And you're have,
there's certain types of
interactions that you can control,
how much people penetrate your boundaries.
Sometimes you can't.
But when you can,
it's good to just take
a moment and assess,
like, what about, you know,
"Where do I draw the line
with this relationship?"
On social media or real life, you know?
It's just, it's good to say,
you know, I am empowered to say,
"I need to draw the line here."
Hmm.
Or there,
or wherever it may be.
Agreed.
Danielle. Let's hit one more.
Hey, Rhett and Link. This
is Jake, from Illinois.
And I could not survive my teenage years
without school assemblies.
Quite literally.
Because when I was about
a freshman or sophomore,
we had a school assembly talking about
the dangers of getting out
of your car when light poles,
or telephone poles rather,
fall and you're in your car.
Because we had a girl that
actually got out of her car
when this happened.
And she's lucky the
wires weren't live still
because otherwise she would've
got electrocuted and died.
But she lived, and she,
along with some other professionals,
gave a assembly
and informed the students what to do,
if that was to ever happen to them.
Fast forward like two years
later, maybe a year later.
And me and my friends
decided to go storm chasing.
And sure enough,
the telephone poles
that we were driving by,
start falling like dominoes.
And we get lucky.
And our car is right in
between two that fall.
So we're trapped in between
two, can't go anywhere.
And because of the education that we got
at this school assembly,
we knew to stay in the car
and would just wait till help
got there to help us out.
And it was a wild experience.
I was very scared, but hey,
I survived my teenage years.
Thanks school assemblies,
I'll never forget that.
Wow, Jake.
You gotta pay attention to
those school assemblies, man.
And now Jake needs to
have a school assembly
where he tells people
not to go storm chasing.
Right?
Well, I mean, I don't know.
Cause if, well.
The thing about the wires
fallin' on your car,
is that if you step out,
you're creating,
you're completing the
circuit with the ground
and it's gonna go through you.
It's trying to get to the ground.
Hoo wee. Wow.
So, I think that's a great
way to end this discussion,
is by reminding people,
if you're in a car with a rogue
power line draped over you,
don't get out of the car.
Wait for help to come.
Take it from Jake.
Do you remember anything
from a school assembly?
Only thing I remember
from a school assembly
is that one from the prom.
Oh yeah.
The, where the,
the guy would come in and show all,
slideshow.
Do they still do that?
Slideshow of-
Intoxicated people.
Drunk driving?
Who then have been maimed.
Good killed.
God there's things I
cannot get outta my mind.
Yeah.
And I gotta say it,
right now. It was effective.
I wasn't about to drive drunk.
Uh-uh.
Because I wasn't even-
Especially on a moped.
cause I wasn't even drinking.
But like, yeah man.
Yeah.
Like I think any time I'm
faced with the opportunity
to drive while intoxicated,
which is not often.
If you think about that,
that's good.
Schools have got it.
The first thing
comes to mind is, "This is
really stupid, don't do this."
And the second thing is,
"That doggone school assembly
in 1996 before the prom."
Mm hmm.
I'm gonna give a rec,
but first I just wanna give a teaser
to next week's "Ear Biscuit".
Rhett's gonna...
How do I, how do I put this?
Well I dunno.
I'm, there's gonna be a
big episode next week.
Teaser.
Where Rhett's gonna unleash some news,
that,
you know honestly?
I think it'd be good for
us to process it together.
Okay.
So, be sure to come back next week.
And I will say that-
For some news.
I won't be,
this won't be breaking the seal,
if you, you know,
follow me on social media.
Right.
So you're gonna, you probably
already know about this.
You probably already know
about it right now, actually.
If you know about his project.
Yeah. But we're gonna talk all about that.
Why it's happening.
His personal project.
We're going all the details next week,
here on "Ear Biscuits".
Hashtag "Ear Biscuits", let
us know what's going on.
I'll leave you with a rec.
You rec'd this to me.
You may have rec'd it on the podcast.
I think I did, but I can't remember.
I have to rec this 'cause I just,
I finally got around to
watching it a few nights ago.
The documentary called,
"Beauty is Embarrassing"
about the artist, Wayne White.
If you're a creative person
and you want to just,
this is just a profile of an artist,
who just his,
he's just got this
artistic ethos about him,
that's just very inspiring.
He designed a lot of the
puppets for PeeWee's Playhouse.
Did a lot of other things.
He's an eclectic creator of art.
And it's just a fun podcast,
to just like, be
introduced to Wayne White.
Podcast?
I said podcast, I'm just-
It's not a podcast.
It's a documentary.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's just like an hour,
you know, an hour and a half,
get it on Amazon Prime.
Very inspiring.
Very inspiring character.
Yep.
"Beauty is Embarrassing."
If you're into artistic
profiles, this is a fun one.
Thank you for your voicemails.
Keep leaving them, ask us questions,
participate in the prompts that
we put out on social media.
Tell us what you think,
what you want,
what you fear,
what you love.
♪ 1-888-EARPOD1 ♪
And you might get featured
at the end of an episode,
just like right now.
So basically I'm just gonna say,
I could not have survived my teenage years
without Cheez Whiz.
Rhett, I know you know
what that one means.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
I could not have survived my teenage years
without scrambled Pay-Per-View channels.
If you know, you know.
Hey Rhett and Link.
Long time listener, first time caller.
To answer your prompt,
the "What could I not live
without as a teenager?"
I'd have to say you guys.
It's kind of cheesy,
but I've been watching you for a long time
since I was real little, about seven.
And I've really loved
growing up with you guys.
And you've been like
parental figures to me.
But if you wanted a real
answer, pornography.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.